[موسيقى]
شده الشتاء تحتضنها ثلاثه مواسم مقسمه على
ثلاثه شهور المربعانيه الشبط العقارب تبدا
الشده مع بدايه المربعانيه او والديسمبر
وتنتهي مع نهايه العقارب اخر شهر فبراير
ونحن الان في اول اسابيع موسم العقارب وهو
موسم بدايه الاعتدال لكنه لا يخلو من
هجمات برد مباغته ولهذا اسموه بل عقرب ليه
لان برده يلدغن على حين غفله من امرنا
وعدد ايامه 39 يوما مقسمه على ثلاثه نجوم
ساعد ذابح وسعد بلع وسعد وسعود والعامه
يسمونه عقرب السم لامبردها يقتل كما يقتل
السم وعقرب الدم لان بردها يدمي ولا يقتل
وعقرب الدسم لانها تتوائم مع موسم الربيع
ندخل عقاربي لم يكن لعدا ولكن لخبث تقتضيه
طباعها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وهل الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون اذا دخلت
العقارب ترى الخير قارب وخيريه العقارب
تتسم فيه نهايه البرد القارس وبدايه
انتشار الربيع فاول العقارب موسم بذره
الست منتصف العقارب جراند خامس ربيع طامس
واخر العقارب موسم بياع الخبل عباته وهو
موسم لدغ العقرب احفظ لسانك ايها الانسان
لا يلدغنك انه ثعبان كم في المقابر من
قتيل لسانه كانت تهاب لقائه
الشجعان
[موسيقى]